learning how to identify possible data
is a fundamental skill if you're going
to work with data
you have to see data when it isn't
obvious
data is truly everywhere and it is
almost always more than what you
initially think
let's start with this simple example of
a chair
think of what data you see when you see
this chair
did you notice that it has a color what
about the material
and what about it being furniture if we
dig deeper for even more data you will
see that the chair has dimensions like
height and weight
these things impact our shipping and the
cost of shipping
that takes us even further like
suppliers
where are the locations of those
suppliers how many suppliers do we have
and how many chairs do they have in
stock
what about all the dates related to the
chair like when it's ordered
when it was shipped when it's delivered
again identifying the not so obvious
data can help you in a million different
ways as you start your analyst career
try your data lens out on the items that
you work with and see how much data you
identify
this will help you to ask better
questions in almost every data related
project
it's important to understand what data
looks like
most people will think about the values
of data
but to an analyst the data looks like
data types
fields and values a data type defines
what type of data goes into a field
a date data type will contain only dates
numbers only numbers
it also controls what you can do with
the data values of that data type
for example if i need to add 30 days
then i want to be sure i'm working with
a date data type
data has so many types and each program
has different ways to handle and format
them
now let's get started with the basics
common data types are text or string
date date and time and number when we
first look at data on any data set
it's typically the field headings and
the values that we see
but as a data analyst remember you must
dig deeper to see what types are behind
the data
here's an example you see both the field
heading and the value
the field name is first name but the
field value is robin
field headings and all the values then
go on to make up records or record sets
this probably looks familiar to you the
spreadsheets you encounter are probably
structured with records like this
already
this gives us a lot of flexibility when
working with data tools
depending on the data you encounter it
might be your first step to get it into
a record set format
data tools you will work with will
expect the data in this record format